ce mardi 2 janvier à 9h dans cette salle
de fitness de montigny le bretonneux
habille déjà en train de transpirer pour
tenir l'une de ses résolutions de
l'année 2018 faire du sport moi non moi
je veux faire du point g et
tonifier demeurera fermée là j'ai
presque même pas une heure je mets 10
milles de course du monde de vélo il
fait deux dramas et si j'ai le temps je
perds 25 minutes mais dans une salle en
hausse et la caf
comme habile sont des dizaines de
sportifs dans cette salle amateurs ou
expérimentés à se lancer dans cette
course pour perdre les 2,3 kg stockées
en moyenne pendant les fêtes plutôt
détox de l'époque ce parce que grosse
prise de preuves blockhaus plus de poids
le point en soit on l'a on l'a depuis
on évacue on les fait d'évacuer un
combat continu avant soit on sort des
repas un peu nous offre là pas trop
envie de se lever bon on vient quand
même ça fait du bien bah ça fait du bien
au moral de voir qu'on est nombreux à
être dans la même entre guillemets
galère un phénomène qui permet aux
salles de sport d'enregistrer deux à
trois fois plus d'inscriptions janvier
le deuxième mois le plus rentable après
septembre pour le monde du fitness en
fait en janvier souvent on rencontre des
gens qui ont qui n'ont jamais accédé à
une salle de sport ou qui accéda qu'ils
ne font plus de sport depuis un certain
nombre d'années et qui prennent
conscience justement à ce moment précis
de l'année que les faut qu'ils se
remettent à bouger un peu quoi le mois
de janvier enregistre donc un pic de
fréquentation mais gare à la
démotivation
seulement un français sur deux inscrit
juste après les fêtes poursuit le sport
après le mois de mars